foreign  [Music]  [Music]  you will never have my permission where  is she no come on  we have to go  here you need to help my daughter  load up let's get to it  do you think anyone's following us  we're okay it's Mark over the sheriff  we'll make it right in the end  my men and I are here to bring that boy  in alive so if you're here in some sort  of Vendetta slide with the complicate  things  Mary I will find him and you're welcome  to every piece of him when I'm done  you hear me  there's some control here  I love you your horses carry this sent  to death did you wander around this  desert like a bunch of children  lawmen enforcing your loss on foreign  land I am tired of it  it's not the way  peace doesn't follow death  [Music]  [Music]